I'm running for president because I
think we need someone who's saying the
most obvious thing in the world which is
our government is broken our Congress is
broken we don't have a system that
responds to the ordinary voter we live
in a system where the tiniest fraction
of the one percent funds that campaigns
that the candidates rely on to get
elected the tiniest fraction 400
Americans have given half the money in
this election cycle so far that's not
American democracy that's banana
republic democracy yannis love my
sponsors I don't know who my sponsors
are because the way we funded this
campaign is crowd-sourced it in a
Kickstarter like way I said if we raised
a million dollars in less than 30 days I
would run and if we raise that money
then the campaign was on if we didn't
then I was going to give the money back
we did it and now I'm running and the
money we take is only from citizens we
can't take any PAC money we can't take
any foreign money we don't take any
corporate
so David your question is exactly the
right question what we need to do is to
rally america to insist on fixing that
system so the difference between my
candidacy and there's is that i want to
run a campaign that raises above the
partisan divide in america today to
rally people to a point that every
American whether you're Republican
independent or Democrat ought to agree
with that we ought to have a
representative democracy that represents
us equally and if we can rally america
to that i think we have the power the
mandate enough to force that Congress to
fix itself and if we don't we just have
a regular partisan election then what
we'll see if the next four years the
next eight years is more stale mecke
more partisan stalemate nothing will
happen and for the democrats the party
which is the party of yes the dem party
that has ideas that they want America to
adopt that would be a disaster and that
is exactly why I'm
miles you're asking me the hardest
question for this campaign because what
we found as I've announced this idea of
the referendum president is people get
very focused on the resignation part and
they miss the critical middle step which
is we passed the most important civil
rights legislation in 50 years now
obviously the vice president's important
regardless of who the president is and I
want a vice president who excites the
Democratic base in a way that brings
this party alive enough to be able to
win in the general election but people
who've done that so far I think are
people like Bernie Sanders or Elizabeth
Warren these are exactly the kind of
people I think who would make this
ticket irresistible to most Americans
jose i think the assassination of JFK
you know of course is part of three
major assassinations in that decade
which because of the tragedy all of them
Dukes assassination of dr. King and the
two Kennedy brothers
forces as constantly to imagine it can't
just be crazy people who did this I fear
the least that many people have that it
is something was the government impact
is behind that Kennedy assassinations
King assassination and I believe we have
a duty to try to make it possible for
people to believe the truth if in fact
the truth is that it is a bunch of crazy
people who did so I would love the
government to be as transparent as it
possibly could to end as much as it can
any of these skepticism
so Michael I think Donald Trump has done
the best of things and the worst of
things the best of things is in the
Republican Party we pulled back the
curtain on the way money corrupts the
system standing on debate stage calling
out every one of those candidates for
presidents emphasizing the way all of
them were dependent on large donors to
fund their campaigns because it brought
all of us to recognize in a cross
partisan way the corrupting influence of
money in politics but he's been the
worst of influences to his appeal to the
worst of America through the hatred he's
expressed to immigrants in America i
think is outrageous and i think it
demeans the American political process
to imagine a candidate as prominent as
he appealing to this base and horrible
part of America and I think more
fundamentally we need to recognize
Donald Trump's ability to be a candidate
like this raises the question of how we
allow the political process to be
captured and manipulate and whether we
should have a better system for making
sure that participation and media covers
politics so that America gets a broader
view of who these candidates are
so Kevin Bernie's campaign and my
campaign are fundamentally different
bernie is identifying all the amazing
things that we as Americans have to do
and most of the things he's talking
about I completely agree with but he is
not given a plan for how's he gonna how
he's going to fix this corrupted system
he has not he has not committed himself
to fixing this corrupted system first
he's identified the problems of
corruption he's pointed to the right
answers but checking off a box is not a
plan and what I have said is we have to
commit ourselves to fixing this
democracy first if any of these amazing
ideas that he's talking about or even
possible so my referendum presidency is
about making it possible for somebody
like Bernie Sanders to actually achieve
what he's talking about he wants to
achieve Alan it's incredibly important
for me to get ins and Bates there's no
campaign if I can't get into the first
of the second debate so we are working
as hard as we can to make it possible to
be in that debate but how to do it is a
really hard question I'm not a
politician and what they've done is set
up rules where politicians presumptively
get to be on that stage I'm not a
billionaire so I can't force myself on
stage by spending millions of dollars to
get their name recognition necessary to
get above their arbitrary cutoff
percentage this is a serious campaign
yet that's in outsiders campaign and the
challenge for an outsider's campaign is
to force the insider to let us on stage
and so far they've not allowed us to be
on that stage
karisma the fundamental focus my
campaign was to restore equality to this
political system I think the black lives
matter movement is the most important
political movement to remind America
about how it has betrayed its
fundamental commitment of course when
America was born we had to trade that
commitment through slavery but then
after 150 years of fighting to end
slavery a battle that began when the
first black slave was brought to America
and put in Chains we finally ended that
sin in America but it took a hundred
years before we could actually deliver
on the promise of equal rights a hundred
years before finally there was a Civil
Rights Act that actually protected
african-americans from discrimination
and the Voting Rights Act that actually
gave them the right to vote but for the
last 50 years we have betrayed the
promise of those civil rights statutes
and the product is a world where we have
radical inequality and radical
inequality that is clearly identifiable
on the basis of race we have betrayed
the promise that we made that promise is
finally something we have to deliver on
so Joshua the NRA has power for two
different reasons one reason it has
power is that there are many Americans
who believe fundamentally and what they
understand the 2nd amendment to
guarantee them the right to the right to
bear arms and those people vote they are
powerful influence in our political
system because they exercise their
political power regularly and reliably
but the second reason the NRA has power
is the incredible amount of money which
the gun companies feed to the NRA both
to support that organization and also
support the work a political work of
that organization but in a system where
eighty-nine percent of americans support
background checks removing this
ridiculous exemption for private sales
of guns which exempt about forty percent
of sales from background checks in a
world where eighty-nine percent support
that and the president can't even get
that passed that's not because a bunch
of people are voting that's because
there's tons of money in the system that
is improperly in the system and we have
to find a way to change that
so Logan I think I might be the most
liberal drug decriminalization person in
this campaign I think we've wasted an
extraordinary amount of money and human
lives in this ridiculous war on drugs a
war which has not only destroyed whole
communities in the United States but
destroyed whole countries in South
America and across the world and so I
would move as aggressively as I could to
stop this war and to decriminalize in a
way that facilitated the ending of this
black market destructive economy so yes
I would support legalization of cannabis
at the federal level I would encourage
safety regulations of that drug so that
when people consumed it they had some
confidence they were consuming safe
drugs as opposed to drugs that have
painted material which many drugs didn't
the black market do and I would admit
that we live in a society where people
want to experiment in that way and we
should not criminalize that behavior
because it's not then we should be
worrying about it's the incredible war
and the cost of that war it should be
the focus of federal policy
hello soil from Twitter which is an
interesting name I think student dad is
one of the most important problems to
confront and I think to confront it
we're going to have to fundamentally
change the way our system works here's
the reality if we take on student debt
we take on the most powerful political
interest in America today those banks
who defend this system where they have
guaranteed loans yet charged incredibly
high interest rates to the borrowers are
going to fight this reform with every
ounce of energy they've got and so if
we're going to have a chance to win we
have to change the system where they
have so much power not because of the
number of votes they can cast because of
a corporation of course can't cast votes
but we have to change the fact that they
have power because of the money they can
deploy inside the system
so one my view about immigration is
perhaps the most radically inclusive
view about immigration of any of the
candidates who are running for president
let's start with what the word Americans
mean I think we have an extraordinary
number of Americans who are not citizens
of America there are people who come to
this country they devote their life to
this country their dreams in their
future are tied to this country they
work in the Central Valley of California
for incredibly low wages terrible
working conditions environments that
give them cancer and cause their
children incredible burdens they live
all across the middle part of the United
States they live in Miami as they build
a culture and a community Miami which is
distinctive but tied to America these
are all Americans and my view is our
government should work as hard as it can
to give these Americans the right to be
citizens all of them I would be as
inclusive as possible I wouldn't include
people who have come to this country and
committed crimes come to this country
and done harm come to this country and
our threat to that country those are
legitimate reasons not to include people
within our political society but we have
no right we white Americans who came to
this country without a visa who came to
this country without the permission of
the Native Americans who were here in
this country we have no right to exclude
others from this country in the way that
we have in the past 50 years
bye